-John, we always
like to do something exciting
when you're on the show,
and since your new movie, "F9,"
has a lot of fast-paced action,
I thought it'd be fun
to see what kinds of things
we could get done
in just 30 seconds.
It is time for
"30 Seconds To..."
-♪ 30 Seconds To... ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-John, for this first challenge,
we have 30 seconds to
transport as many Skittles
from one plate to another
using a spoon
that we hold in our mouth.
[ Laughter ]
Whoever has the most Skittles
on their plate wins.
Does this sound good?
-Sounds great.
[ Laughter ]
-This is what I'm talking about.
Here you go.
This is the type of action that
you want on "The Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Drum roll ]
Let's get 30 seconds --
[ Laughter ]
Let's get 30 seconds
on the clock.
Ready, set, go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How you doing it?
-I'm doing good.
How you doing, man?
-How you doing?
-I'm doing great.
Are you doing all right?
-I think I'm okay.
You know, the kids are good.
Nancy's good.
[ Laughter ]
There's only one there.
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was some intense --
Wait a sec.
I can already just see
you crushed me.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughter ]
How were you doing yours?
Why -- Why are you
so much better than me?
-Just slow and steady, man.
You're always so excited.
I knew this one
would get the best of you.
[ Laughter ]
Just taking life
one Skittle at a time, bro.
[ Laughter ]
-No one says that.
All right.
[ Laughter ]
Congratulations.
For this next challenge,
here's my revenge, here we go.
-Okay.
-We're have take
Solo cups, okay?
One at a time
from the top of the stack
and move them to the bottom
until the blue Solo cup --
-Okay.
I think this is more
your wheelhouse.
Yes, I have a blue Solo cup
at the bottom,
and I have to get it to the top
by removing the cups --
You know the drill.
-Yeah, exactly, yeah.
Normally, my Solo cups have
some type of liquid in them,
but, yeah, here we go.
All right, so, whoever has moved
the blue cup further up
the stack wins.
Let's get 30 seconds...
-Blue cup to the finish.
-...on the clock.
Ready, set, go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How much time?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How much time?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I did it!
[ Ding! ]
-You did it, you did it.
You got me by about
a half a cup.
-Yeah, you got me by about
That's you.
-Yes!
Let's go to commercial.
No, I'm just kidding.
All right.
Big deal.
So, big deal.
You won one, I won one.
Now it's time for the --
-Yeah, this is the tiebreaker.
We got to do something big.
-Yeah, this is
the final challenge here.
Here's what we have to do.
We have a tissue box
full of ping-pong balls.
Now we have to tie these belts
around our waists.
-Yep.
-And then you have to
shake out as many balls
as we can.
[ Laughter ]
-That seems right.
-In 30 seconds.
Whoever has --
-Do -- Does --
This is gonna be
a weird question.
Do the balls go in the front?
[ Laughter ]
-That's a great question.
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
That wasn't even in the box.
I just had that in my pants.
Sorry, hold on.
[ Laughter ]
All right, look --
-I'll spot you one.
I'll spot you one.
-That's a friend.
And the judges here
are saying it goes on the butt.
-Oh, okay, great.
All right.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-This should be interesting.
-All right.
So, here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughing ]
Can we get --
Can we get 30 seconds
on the clock?
[ Drum roll ]
Ready, set, go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How you doing, John?
[ Laughing ]
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wait for it.
Wait for it.
Wait.
You're gonna love this.
[ Grunts ]
Two balls.
[ Laughter ]
-Only four balls left
in this guy right here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
[ Ding! ]
John Cena!
-Jimmy Fallon,
you are the grand champion!
-I love you, bud.
I'll say this.
Next time you come, you got to
bring your balls, okay?
[ Laughter ]
-I will do that.
-Thank you.
-John Cena, everybody!
That's my man!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"F9" is in theaters this Friday!